With the no more tables technique,
below a certain viewport width,
the table is collapsed and resembles
a long list, as opposed to a table data.
The nice thing about this
technique is all of the data is
visible no matter what
the size of the viewport is.
Let's take a look with
the baseball score again.
In a wider viewport,
everything looks good,
but as the viewport shrinks,
the table collapses.
Every column has essentially become its
own row with the table header beside it.
Using a media query, I need to tell
the table that below a certain width,
in this case 500 pixels, I don't
want it to act like a table anymore.
Inside my media query, I'm going
to force all table, thead, tbody,
th, tr and
td elements to render as display block.
Next, I need to get rid
of the table header.
I could set display none, but that would
cause accessibility problems for people
using screen readers because the browser
won't tell them the column headers.
Instead, I'm just going to position
the content way off screen.
Since the table cells are now displayed
as full width block elements, I need to
add some left padding and also set the
position on these elements to relative.
To add the row labels, I'm going to
use the before pseudo selector and
add td before, and inside, I'll set
the position to left: 6 pixels so
that I get it positioned
in the right place.
Now I need to add the content.
I could put the labels in my CSS,
but that's icky and
will mean that these styles
will only work for this table.
Instead, I'll use
content: attr(data-th).
That will then pull the values from
the data-th of each of the td elements.
Here, let me show you.
And there you have it.
That data-th is used as the label for
each of the rows.